I will transition now to introduce our
keynote speaker and I have notes for
that too Donald Kaufman is the director
of the Microsoft research lab here in
Redmond and as such is a position of
great responsibility and inside's
directing a lab that does research in
all fields of computer science he does
his research on his own and that focuses
on data management in the cloud and the
challenge is about making it cheaper
more valuable and secure he has a lot of
the distinguished accomplishments under
his belt I'll just mention a couple he's
an SEM fellow and he's been for about
four years
chair of the ACM Sigma interest group
but the one that really caught my
attention is that over this summer he
has devoted himself to write a book
about computer science for teenagers all
those in German so I haven't haven't had
a chance to really parse it completely I
know it's about computer science because
he has arrows and boxes so you know it's
computer science because he has those
things in it but I will let her I with
him him talk more about his work and
himself so without further ado my
pleasure to introduce no no Cosmo thank
you
I'll just get my presentations as oh
thanks gonzo for giving my elevator
pitch
I was already sweating and said oh I
have to give it an elevator pitch but
essentially I am gonna give an elevator
pitch but there's some things for the
book just before while I'm setting up I
have four children among others three
teenage daughters and they kept on
asking me on why did I do computer
science and that was actually a pretty
tough question for me to answer and I
found out that I actually never answered
that question well so actually to take a
step back I joined Microsoft five years
ago and before that I was on the faculty
of ETH Zurich for 15 years so this is my
second life my second career and so at
some point I found out that I had no
good answer so I
have went through a whole professor
career without answering the question
why is computer science something that
why was i fortunate to or lucky to study
computer science so that's what this
book is about what I will talk about a
little bit so I actually I want to you
just do an elevator pitch I'll talk for
about 20 minutes and then open it up
I'll talk a little bit about my
perspective what I think is the next
frontier the next generation the next
era of computing and but this is my
personal view as gonzo said this lab
does everything and I don't really here
I don't really prescribe and say well
this is we should all be working on then
on the global AI supercomputer this is
not how MSR works MSR is bottom up and
everybody creates their own vision and
this is my personal vision and I don't
mandate anybody to share it but just the
way I how I think about it but before I
do that I want to give you a little bit
of of an overview of Microsoft Research
so this is kind of like Microsoft
Research in one slide
it's about thousand people pretty a
little more than a third is here in
Redmond and the rest is gathered all
around the world so this is by far the
biggest site if you think about these
thousand people it's two-thirds our
researchers and think of a researcher as
a professor that's pretty much how we
think of researchers and that's also how
we how we kind of evaluate them and in
some sense but they're free but they
also we believe they all could be
professors and top universities around
the world and they have all the freedom
they have a research agenda the
differences they collaborate maybe more
than at least I was used to in in the in
and when I was in academia ETH I don't
know whether you know ETH has has has
fairly large group so every professor
has a little small little fiefdom here
this is very collaborative because we
don't have as many students we do have
students and we're very fortunate that
you're coming here today but of course
we have also the internship program but
mostly we do our work and collaboration
between researchers but also we have
engineers designers program managers
because we also build stuff and the big
difference between ms our industry
research and academia is that we don't
really think in lockstep of what a PhD
thesis is we try to think bigger
sometimes also smaller but we really
don't need to think about PhD sized
contributions thesis as contributions we
can go much bigger or also smaller if
that is fun and makes sense but we also
build things and we really our kind of
our mission essentially is I'll come to
that a little bit but is really to make
the world a better place right it's not
our focus is not in educating people
although we do that as well but and grow
people and I think this is a marvelous
place to learn and do things I'm
learning definitely a lot but the focus
is really to make the world a better
place we are very very open and engaged
with the academic community I think many
of the conference's where you go you
will find Microsoft is a sponsor and you
will also find if it is a sponsor many
of our people will be there and you can
interact with them and one of the great
things that we do is we we can talk and
we can do and with everybody we are
totally free and open whereas product
groups at Microsoft sometimes they have
confidentiality and all that we don't
have that and they don't talk to their
competitors we we work freely with
Google with Facebook with everybody ok
just to give you another kind of
perspective that's we're pretty proud of
this so if you think about 650
professors that's a pretty serious
University and so you could also assume
that we we do have some
credentials right so we have five Turing
Award winners which is ETH for example
has only one of course they don't have
650 professors so yeah actually in the
ratio we are doing worse than ETH but
anyway yeah yeah well let me not go
further on that part okay
so what we do is essentially three our
mission are three things actually I'm
not sure how interesting this is but I
often give this kind of presentation
also to customers so because they they
won't understand what Microsoft why is
Microsoft doing this and there's a
there's a good reason there's good
reason why this is good for the company
and this is why I'm not worried that
Microsoft Research is gonna disappear
anytime soon at this point Microsoft is
all about innovation our CEO said that
kind of one of the first things he said
was this industry doesn't value or
respect tradition it only respects
innovation and so we are a big big part
of the innovation of the of the company
and so the the way the company thinks
about it is it's not that there's this
group and think tank also impressed
innovation I think they're the big
reason why you are also here is this
part in order to kind of distill the
innovation or get something that changes
the world we really have to engage in
the scientific community and do thinking
and think about things in the world and
about science in a way that is totally
unconstrained and has nothing to do with
the company so when we talk about the
advancing the state-of-the-art in
computer science this is exactly the
academic research that has no ties and
no kind of constraints in the same way
as you would call academic research now
academia has other responsibilities and
accountabilities and writing grants we
don't have to write grant proposals
although all that is comes naturally and
just flows to us and does teaching we
don't do that but then we have to do
other things of course as well and that
is
what once we have something we do really
want to get it out into into the real
world and that's what this part is about
rapidly transferring innovation so when
we have something we will engage with
product rules with open-source community
whatever with the scientific community
with whatever makes sense to advance not
only the state of the art but we
actually make it real and that's why we
also we build stuff a lot and then and
again of course the company hopes that
quite a bit of that will will lead to
things in the company and and we we have
a great track record many parts of Asia
would not be possible without research
though yeah we were talking about
networking all of the networking all the
leaders they were used to be researchers
in Microsoft Research being is another
example where kind of the company never
really believed in search until they
really had to they had no choice into
believing it and then they started being
and they could do that because Microsoft
research their connect is another great
example and then one of the things and
is incubating disruptive it's kind of
there's a there's controversy between
there's a redesign of that sometimes we
also talk about securing the vibrancy
and future of the company but one way
you could also interpret that is we we
kind of take care of people and and try
to grow them to do become innovators and
entrepreneurs and of course we were also
responsible for attracting and hiring
great talent and this is usually the
third pillar okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna go a
little bit faster but one of the things
that we do I mean I've I have slides on
how we kind of create value to the
company but then I usually animated and
one one way I put it how the company
looks at us so if I run into
satya our CEO on the hallway he will
always the the the thing that he will
ask me he will say Donald what is new
and I think this is I thought so he does
that really this is this is true and I
always thought about that is this
because it's kind of like oh yeah do I
have something new or not but actually
this is something really positive uh-huh
because he asked that because he expects
something new which means he is excited
about getting something new and plus he
is kind of confident that we keep on
producing something new and so the the
one way to put Microsoft Research is our
job is essentially to create surprises
and our leadership wants to be surprised
and it's just I think it's really really
nice to work for a company and where the
leadership wants to be surprised because
sometimes managers they don't want to be
surprised right they just want to do
their business as usual and it every
kind of disruption is bad so what I want
to talk a little bit about for the next
ten minutes is is why these are the
golden days of Microsoft Research and I
think you're fairly yeah so throughout
my career and I have now a longer career
I've been around this slide has been
kind of you could have at every point in
time you could have shown this slide it
just has gotten better and better but it
is actually becoming kind of
exponentially better and better the
world is becoming digital was true 25
years ago but now we're kind of we're
breaking some of the the frontiers and
the world is reinventing itself so what
I'm going to talk a little bit about is
what I think is going to be the next
generation of computing so for those I
don't know whether you think it taught
about the history of computing but it
has been a little bit like a pendulum we
have had five generations of computing
it started like with the main frame or
the the big machines that you know from
Manhattan Project which essentially did
number-crunching scientific computing a
line reservation and so on very
centralized computing the second
generation was kind of from a very
centralized to distributed was the PC
area and the PC era essentially what was
the killer application of the PC era hmm
pun spreadsheets yeah productivity yes
spreadsheets is good world wide web is
actually the third one so spreadsheets
Word PowerPoint but actually just name
it games right gaming was that's what
that's why Microsoft still is in the
gaming thing you can you cannot play
games on a mainframe computer yeah III
program the mainframe computer so you
typed in your thing and then you came
back the next day to get the printout of
your results usually you're stacked up
right but with a piece and it gaming is
not very fun in this environment because
you make a shot you come back next day
and certain myths right it's not how you
play games the next so that was very
distributed right every PC everybody
plays their game of course for
themselves
then came the the web essentially that
is again a very centralized architecture
and what was it what is the killer app
of the the web email yeah I I don't
think email is the but I'll put it more
generally it's so social networks and
sharing of data yeah so if you have a PC
sharing data is actually yeah that's
yeah you need to do email but email is
very clumsy and sharing data it's it's
good to kind of do a message but if you
the world wide web came across because
you wanted to share scientific documents
that's how Tim berners-lee invented it
okay so the next wave is the smartphone
obviously again in the decentralized way
and and the the killer app of that
obviously is Google Maps sense health
the wellness applications every
thing that you do kind of suddenly you
digitalize your your kind of your world
right you start digitizing the world the
the iPhone what is really great or the
smartphone what is really great about it
is it it has sensors it gets and how
watches and so on they all sense the
world okay then the next generation is
the cloud obviously what is the killer
application of the cloud virtualization
is not the killer application that's the
technology that drives the cloud with
the application why people are so doing
this in the cloud is is AI because again
it's a central architecture it is
bringing all the data into the cloud it
has massive amounts of computing
resources in the cloud to learn models
and do that so I just want to go how I
think about kind of where we're gonna go
next so again this is this may be the
slide I'm gonna I'm gonna make this
statement which again has been true for
the last 70 years your next computer is
a supercomputer but I'm going to give it
with a with a special twist so so I set
this pendulum but throughout this
pendulum there have been two curves that
have been totally steady and you could
have drawn them in any kind of time
scale and they would have all looked the
same and you can can probably or maybe
continue to draw them so the size of a
computer over history always was became
smaller and smaller and the number of
machines is this famous quote of TJ
Watson in 1960 I think he said there's a
worldwide market for three computers
right there's a very funny miss quotes
right miss predictions Bill Gates also
had a very funny one does it is do
people know what Bill Gates predicted
which was really really dumb he
predicted that computers will never have
more than 64 kilobytes of main memory
yeah that's didn't happen right so
anyway the number grew obviously beyond
three Watson was wrong and IBM actually
did fairly well nevertheless
but at some point they did so what I'm
gonna argue and this is a and this is
what I I want to kind of tell you that
of course you can go down down down and
up up but I think we should start
thinking for the next kind of maybe
generation of distributed computing we
should think about that the world is has
exactly one machine yeah
in the same way as a car as a PC today
or a smartphone is not many machines it
has many processes as it has many
storage units has many network
interfaces right it has an Ethernet
wireless bluetooth we think of a PC as
one computer we think of a car as one
computer yeah a car does anybody know
how many computers you would kind of as
a mechanical engineer a BMW does anybody
have a how many processes a a D BMW
house anybody know anybody has I guess
it's about 200 processors 200 200
processes yeah and of course some
engineers think about it as to each
processor kind of the processor that is
the nav system the processor that
controls the injection of of gasoline
into the engine and so on those are all
individual computers that are programmed
but for us really it is one single big
computer and it's one big machine and
what I'm going to argue is and this is
the way I'm kind of thinking about about
research in computer science is well
let's think about this world as one
computer and and that is a essentially
what I mean I'm not going to go through
the whole talk but this is a essentially
what I want to wanted what the world I
want to drive home so when you think
about this this world you can you can
have it as one as an internal
perspective is what we as researchers
mostly have been doing like building
of small devices and computers but most
people like we'll think of this and that
this is what I call the external
perspective as one computer and they
will want to program it they will want
to optimize it and they will want to
secure it as one big machine and and of
course both perspectives are important
as a database researcher I mostly have
this internal perspective as every of
these kind of machines I need to somehow
program and need to make sure that it
gets the data that it needs but I am
forcing myself to also have the
perspective of of most of our customers
who don't really care and this is maybe
the virtualization aspect where data
lies they just want it to work if I am a
so Mary is an HCI researcher right at
the moment when I program for HCI let's
say I would program as I have a new idea
of an app I would program the smartphone
app but really as a user yes maybe I'll
use the smartphone app and I'm looking
at my smartphone all day but really what
I care about is the experience that I
get and that should be really decoupled
from the smartphone app yeah so it
should be if I'm looking at my
smartphone app I want the experience my
information to be on the screen of the
smartphone app but when I watch TV I
want the experience to be kind of move
from the smartphone app to the TV and
this way these are all kind of patterns
that that that that kind of that I think
that can help us to innovate in this
area by thinking rather by thinking
device by device or sensor by sensor or
micro controller by microcontroller or
network link by Network link if we think
about the whole world as a computer and
we want
change it so I'm gonna I'm gonna stop
pretty pretty much here but I'm gonna
give a little bit of overview on on the
the areas that I kind of care about and
gonzo already said we want to make this
more valuable we want to make it
sustainable we want to secure it but
essentially I have examples and to the
the way I think about projects in the
lab is thinking about examples so if you
think about this is the new
next-generation computer then of course
I want I want to think about what is the
killer app of this computer yeah so in
the same way as we had a killer app for
the mainframe a killer app for the PC a
killer app for the web a killer app for
the smartphone a killer app for the
cloud I want to know what can you do if
you take this approach and if you
believe that we are going into that age
what can you do with this computer
mostly in the good sense that you
couldn't do before yeah so I was
mentioning gaming you can do with the PC
you cannot do with a with a with a with
a with a mainframe and there are
examples with kind of one example that I
really like to give is precision
agriculture it's a very known technology
it's kind of most of you will have heard
of precision medicine right where you
kind of well if you have a if you have a
cough in the old days well this is what
you got right everybody got the same and
now with precision medicine means you
kind of target your your therapy but
also your Diagnostics to the to the
individual person or personalized
medicine you can do the same thing for
agriculture how much water what do you
what plants do you grow on a special
field how much water do you give how
many pesticides and so on
the problem with precision agriculture
traditionally has been that you don't
know what's going on in the field what
can you do with this global high
supercomputer you kind of fly because
the sensors that tell you which bugs for
example live on the field
are very expensive what do we do now we
fly we have a drone that flies over it
takes pictures of the field and then
uses Neil's wonderful digital
photography ideas to kind of make sense
what's going on on the field that's a
very cheap sensor the sensors that
really count bugs are still expensive
but a camera that takes pictures is of
course not as precise but now we can do
that of course we also care about the
negative things that you can do with
such a computer and that's why ethics is
such an important topic for us when I
started computer science and I wrote
grant proposals I never had to go
through an ethical review today computer
science you do whatever you wanted what
you do do the smallest thing every
computer scientist needs to go who
writes a grant proposal needs to go at
least a little bit through ethical
reviews because of that because you can
also create negative value with your
technology the second this is the one
that I'm mostly concerned about is how
do we make it sustainable the world and
I'm gonna have a big talk and how what
is an efficient machine and if you now
think of the world as a whole as an
efficient machine that we have to really
completely rethink computing in order to
do that in particular my community is
famous for doing something optimizing
for something that's called bare metal
performance if you have any systems
person here they will agree their metal
performance that's what we want to
achieve and I think what we need to
optimize better for is is a good
utilization of the resources and at the
moment we're clearly doing a very poor
job of that the third thing is security
that we care a lot about and I care a
lot about so if the wall whole world is
connected if this is one big machine
within a car you kind of don't do much
isolation because the car BMW has
manufactured the car as one kind of
monolith for you and the security is
kind of
one monolith but the world is clearly
not one monolith and so you somehow need
to worry and care about security
confidentiality fake news which is
integrity the reliability in in a very
different way and the way I put at
drawing lines and in in inner world
drawing lines in a world that is hyper
connected and the last one is the human
aspect of course how how will people
interact with this machine so with that
I'm going to I'm going to close because
this is a little bit of an overview of
how I personally think about the
questions that we as researchers if we
kind of go and want to an sense help
solve the big problems of the world
these are the questions that I believe
or that I asked myself in everyday in
the things that I do okay and then I ran
a little bit over longer than I wanted
to or wanted to only 20 but now I said
either 25 minutes and really want to
open it up for questions I want to hear
actually from you what you care about
and what motivates you and drives you in
doing in doing your research okay thanks
and yeah so it's a hundred page answer
it was supposed to be and it got longer
and longer it I criterion was that it
was supposed to be readable in one
afternoon which is kind of barely doable
actually now my daughter's say they
don't read anymore they they want to
watch youtube videos so I have to I
might have to we go back to the drawing
board so my my my answer essentially is
is is that
and now I have to kind of condense it
down so so I'm an engineer that's the
one first answer I want to kind of build
stuff and and I think the what computer
science or what is was great for me in
computer sciences that I could easily
build stuff without kind of too much ado
that is really what made computer
science for me attractive now of course
the answer is a little bit more nuanced
and I gave a little bit more but this is
essentially what it boiled down to and
then the the other thing that I that I
point out is that how computer science
is reinventing itself and I think at the
moment with the with I think with also
what I've talked about here it's
reinventing itself again and it's
reinventing itself doesn't mean we're
creating new methodologies like AI might
be a new methodology what I think is
we're reinventing ourselves by creating
new goals so if you think about
mathematics the I mean and if you think
about good what mathematics was about is
creating a perfect number theory right
or physics was always about
understanding the world and it has
always been that right and maybe
relativity theory gave some insights and
how to explain the world but the goal
always has been the same and in computer
science the goal has changed all the
time and that I am and that I think is
pretty cool right and that's why you can
have multiple careers in computer
science yeah
yeah you say that the innovation lies in
doing things you could not do before but
it seems more like computing a lot of
the value of computing it's not having
to do things that you had to do before
so you can think back to the computer
before machines were people right
crunching numbers now we don't have to
crunch numbers or we don't have to
crunch numbers but number crunching
still happens right so why would I want
to create something that I can that lets
me do something without first defining
what I am trying not to do anymore yeah
so I think automating things is is
something that you mean if you can
automate things that you couldn't
automate before that is doing something
that you couldn't do before I think
maybe where this is kind of tweaking
your words here a little bit but I I do
think that we we are getting and this is
why I was mentioning the the precision
agriculture or personalized medicine
those are things that we really couldn't
do before maybe we could do them
conceptually but pragmatically
practically we couldn't do them before
and so I I do think there are it is
worth thinking about things that either
I mean in principle of course you can do
everything and but that that that has
game changing just by this aspect right
there was a reason why you didn't do it
before and now you can do it and they
make the world a better place
but let's not kind of tweak the the
words too much right I mean ultimately
what what we want to achieve here is
make the world a better place
right that's the very simple high-level
undisputable kind of thing but but this
is one way to think about it maybe yeah
and everybody has to find their own
formulation
so I'm just wondering what exactly
drives the projects that Microsoft
research does is that product area is
that the greater company or just like
great ideas that you guys come up with
so what are what drives projects at
Microsoft Research yes so we are a
bottom-up organization so the
researchers the people people like Mary
gonzo Neil with their as I said hundreds
of those they they drive
yeah they drive so we are totally
disconnected in the sense that product
groups don't tell us what to do yeah and
that's very very important because
otherwise we couldn't you I hope you all
know about inventors dilemma right so
that protects the company from inventors
dilemma so the the it's the ideas the
passion but it is not only the idea in
the okay I'm gonna write a great paper
about this it should be an idea it's a
great paper it's great science because
that otherwise other others could
probably do it as well
but it is kind of it has impact in the
in the sense it's gonna make the world a
better place yeah hi I think I actually
have more of like a comment but I when I
think about like the future of computing
I think about one of my favorite talks
by Kemal Bob who talks about how our
societies and our cities are becoming
like tecnópolis is and essentially to be
a functioning citizen you have to have
some type of digital or computational
literacy and so I think if we're going
to think about the future of computing
we also have to understand the ways that
we're fundamentally changing what does
it mean to be a citizen the ways that
we're creating these types of inequities
and social systems of oppression - yeah
I think this I think this belongs into
this this is why I put it this way how
to say what you want as a citizen of
course and and this is where it's kind
of yeah it kind of goes both ways right
essentially you want to say what you
want and then the the machine should
understand but as as you say so for
example Tokyo is going to have 50
million people by 2035 or something like
that or 40 that will completely change
how logistics happen in those cities
completely independent of computing rat
you'll have to essentially flood with
food the city and then people take what
they can get rather the the drive to the
mall is going to disappear and also the
kind of ordering on Amazon might be very
different in those walls because you the
logistics are otherwise just going to
work not going to work because of
density so people will have to adjust as
well and and I completely agree with
that yeah so I think you give us a
preview and during your talk but what do
you miss the most and the least of being
a university professor I it's really
hard to answer that question so I love
being a university professor I I loved
every aspect of it at some point I think
when you get fairly senior the things
that happen is the overhead the
administrative overhead as in a
university professor gets pretty high
you suddenly pull into any kind of
strategic committee and whatever and
that kind of gets gets you but to be
honest I love the job and I had just
seen it and now it's a completely new
job it's very different in and it's very
similar in some aspects the research at
the end is very similar I mean the way I
think hasn't changed my let's say
research taste hasn't changed and
shouldn't change but the way I work with
colleagues versus with students has
checked here I work with colleagues at
the university I work with students both
are great I've had it fifth actually
more than 15 years because of before I
was at ETH I was already at Technical
University of Munich and Heidelberg and
so on so I had it for 20 years
I've seen it I'm now moving on so I
don't
it's not that I'm missing it I loved it
but it was a different world and I had
20 years of that right and now I'm in
year 5 of what I have now
yeah I thank you for that that was great
the question is you know what she asked
and it's more about data integrity in
developing regions of the world so in
the u.s. is this whole thing about fake
news and you know everyone is used to it
in developing context the the idea of
fake news becomes even more problematic
so it's easier for people to forward
messages on whatsapp it's harder to
check if those messages are or simple
messages especially if there's like
end-to-end encryption and with more and
more AI tools you know computer becoming
better it's gonna become much easier for
people to create these contents faster
yeah so in the US computer computer
scientists it's easier for us to be able
to see oh maybe this is something from
deep fake but in developing regions it's
like whatever it's online it's true how
do you how do you balance that like how
do you help these people see that
without being completely paternalistic
yeah I I wish I this is a great comment
amazing comment I wish I had an answer I
mean what I'm putting here is not
answers I'm what I'm saying here those
are questions I don't I think this is a
yeah I haven't I haven't thought about
that particular ads angle and
specifically because but I think there's
a these are great question and I would
love to encourage you to work on these
questions I mean if it's it's you who
will who will fix these questions I mean
I feel I feel a little bit I still feel
that I'm in in the business but I also
feel responsible for quite a bit of the
mess
that is created here and this I think is
one of the big messes that we've created
and that we have to clean up so my kind
of let's put it my generation is we are
thinking about solving some of these and
I think I love the clarity of the
question that you have that will impact
me mostly on that so again you have to
you have to understand that I grew up
very technology centric and some of
these questions will have to be kind of
addressed in a in a much broader context
not it's not going to be only technology
as you kind of hinted at there's a lot
of social aspect human factor aspect and
and I think this is where you're
hopefully your generation is going to be
much better than my generation let's put
it that way because I've been very very
technology focused and I hinted at it a
little bit with the ethics this is
something totally new for me
something that I have to learn and
you're probably Native in in in that and
and I think you're in a much better
position to solve this so and I really
want to would like to encourage you to
think about these things so similar kind
of questions so um I think that if we
look at other aspects of society like
education in the legal system policy
which are still kind of trying to catch
up with internet with mobile computing
how kind of does Microsoft features
think about working with those other
aspects of society to kind of ensure
that when we go to this next
supercomputer in the research sense that
we can actually transition in a societal
sense yeah so actually I think Microsoft
is is doing is doing extremely well not
extremely well there but it's doing kind
of is trying to get there so our
president Brad Smith is really really
active in that so he goes to
universities he thinks about he's a
lawyer right so he thinks about law
enforcement I think he also encouraged
us and this we
this ether committee which is like
ethics and mostly nai which actually
spun out of Microsoft Research has been
very very so the leadership like Brad
Smith has been very supportive I think
we've been kind of at the forefront that
doesn't mean we're doing enough or we're
there but at least we have started early
on to kind of let's not say get the
right structures but to incentivize work
in that area so there are researchers in
the lab here also in New York who for
example think about using AI in the in
the justice system and we know they have
many bad situations where there are
studies that kind of huge bias in their
decision whether somebody should go out
on parole or should should be granted
certain rights and so we I think we are
kind of the the good thing is at
Microsoft we are we are incentivized to
think along those lines that doesn't
mean we're doing well it just means that
the company appreciates it and I think
this is also something that is I like a
lot about working in a company then
versus academia and academia it was very
difficult to kind of get out of your box
I was a database person I got database
grants I got students the best students
of the world came to me because they
wanted to do databases but then they
came and they were amazing students and
I said okay do you want to do a little
bit more than database no no I want to
do databases because then I can be
become a professor at MIT or so one of
my students at MIT that's all you could
say that and because they wanted to it's
very difficult to do actually do that
and and all universities are trying to
do that with interdisciplinary centers
maybe data science is now an opportunity
in a company it's much more agile
all right the the leadership says we are
we are giving you kind of credit kind of
we incentivizing that to work on that
and then things will happen a little bit
more and of course but we are all humans
right changing is is difficult okay does
that kind of answer your question
it's a question over there Thanks I
appreciate the like we are incentivized
to think about it here like I spent my
summer in New York working with the Fate
team on like the ethical applications of
Technology but at the same time like
while I was there Brad Smith came out
and said that not only was he
comfortable like selling artificial
intelligence technology to the US
military he felt it was his patriotic
duty to make sure that we are better the
United States of blowing people up with
robots than any other country in the
world I'm curious as to how being
incentivized to think about the social
implications of our work like works with
a CEO who believes that like it is the
duty of Microsoft to make sure that
people are killed in the most efficient
way possible ok so first of all I don't
so first of all Brad Smith is not the
CEO but anyway he's the president he's a
and I don't know that quote but so let
let me just try to so we live in a
democracy ultimately most of the big
decisions decisions about our society
are not made by Brad Smith or Satya
Nadella or us we Microsoft plays a
particular role and the role that
Microsoft plays is kind of working
towards its strengths developing
technology but how the technology is
used is ultimately the decision of the
the political system and of our society
now I'm not gonna these are these are
now political discussions and if and
Brad Smith has his right to his
political opinion I have my own personal
political opinions but if you think
about a company of hundred thousand more
than hundred thousand people you will
find all sorts of political opinions now
what holds Microsoft together is clearly
not we want the u.s. to be the best to
blow up people that's not what holds
this company together what holds this
company together is the mission of the
company
it's very clearly defined as empowering
people and organizations to achieve more
and all around the world now you can can
interpret that as achieving more in
blowing up people but that's not how we
usually interpret it yeah so what I'm
trying to say is there's gonna be a lot
of politic opinions among people but
this is not the the fabric of Microsoft
I think it when he says something like
that he will say that as Brad Smith and
he will not say that as Microsoft now
how Microsoft makes decisions ultimately
in in in selling technology to the to
the military it will do that according
to its mission and of course yeah we we
are US company and I think we we are
committed to to to operating in the US
and and serving among others the US but
also other countries
hi so I was just mulling on the whole
idea of making world a better place by
computers and I come from India and it's
very diverse in the sense of how people
use computers and I what I've seen in my
research in government is that a lot of
people I mean it creates like a caste
system in terms of how some people are
are good at using computers they have
always used computers and then there's
this older staff who is never used it
and and maybe they're asked to retire
early because they can't use computers
so you know how could a company like
Microsoft I mean you know just like
remove the blinkers of only computers
can make the world a better place and
you don't think about maybe maybe
different things I mean just something
I'm thinking about yeah yeah so I
there's actually an interesting project
in in India from Microsoft Research
which is called 99 dots I don't know
whether you've heard of it it is
essentially I think it's mostly for
diabetes patients to make sure that that
they take their medication yeah super
super close sorry yeah
tuberculosis yeah sorry yeah okay yeah
and it turns out that initially they
started with a lot of computers and
technology at the end the technology is
essentially paper-based right because
that worked much better because that's
where you have the tactile experience
and it has small telephone numbers and
so on it's actually very very low-tech
of course we often think and we are
often in this trap automating computing
digital everything but yes you're right
we have to we have to be grounded in our
like baseline our baseline is not what
is the best way to do it with computers
our baseline is what is the best way to
do it
full-stop right and I think yeah that's
a big trap for that we have to be
careful about falling in hi that was a
great talk I really enjoyed it thanks
let's say I'm a Microsoft researcher and
I have an idea for a product
or a platform is there an established
process to explore it and develop it
yeah that's actually a great question
and the answer is yes and no so there
are in some ways there are kind of ways
and paths how to get there but really it
is know if you want to be really honest
and you have something really new this
is what I call creating new business the
answer is no and I would kind of argue I
will give you an alt an equivalent
thought process for the for the real
world it's outside of Microsoft let's
say I don't know whether you're which
University or from it the Silicon Valley
kind of the startup scene you could ask
is there an established process for a
start-up to become successful yeah and
you would say yes and no yes as well you
get some seed funding you get serious if
one hears be funny at some point you do
an IPO or you kind of sell your company
to to some other company and get there
this is kind of like what we could have
here as well you got asked for seed
funding and so on and you get that and
so here as well but then if you really
go to the bottom of it changing the
world is really really hard right and
there's no established process for doing
that you know they're books written
about it right how to do that but
essentially there's no established
process you have to kind of the the
established process and this is why I
believe that MSI is such a good place is
I would call it navigating uncertainty
right we when we when we innovate we
walk on a minefield and we kind of go
like that and make sure that we and
things change all the time right we're
making assumptions we're creating
hypotheses and this is why I think the
scientific approach and why I strongly
believe in Microsoft in the world is the
right one because it is based on making
hypotheses validating them pivoting and
learning while you go and this is not an
established process
but it is a mindset and it's a mindset
that you actually all are getting as
part of your education as PhD students
that's why we care so much about you
finishing your phd's we would love to
hire you immediately right but no we are
not doing that because we want you to
kind of get this mindset yeah I hope
that answers somewhat the question but
in the yes or no way don't know I want
to make you aware of the time if you
want to answer one more question or I'm
happy to answer one more question my
meeting is with my boss so okay any
minute I miss with that great is highly
appreciated I'm curious you as a super
computer guy what do you think about
your colleagues that are working - it's
quantum computing you have any thoughts
on that yes so first of all I I know
them and there I have a huge amount of
respect I mean this is kind of thinking
really really big I mean Google just
announced a breakthrough I think still
in the in the in the category that they
can do something that we cannot do
before they're not there yet right
everything that they can do now is so
what I really what impresses me is is
one of the things that if you have these
big goals let's say moonshot this is a
moonshot in our terminology what is what
was great about the moonshot was all the
great technologies that we developed so
my frying pan wouldn't exist without the
moonshot and we had we are seeing the
same thing with the quantum computing
research like a very low temperature
computing it might not be the quantum
computer but actually it's a very great
way to do computing the algorithms
thinking about a quantum algorithm we're
seeing we have this Q sharp language and
we're seeing that we the the the
programs we write in Q sharp are
actually beating on a conventional
computer our normal programs just
because they were written thinking about
a quantum computer and that's what I I
think I find exciting about it I don't
know where it is going but
we'll see I hope that it's I hope it
will be successful because there are
some really great applications so
battery is one of them so if we can
develop like a huge breakthrough in
battery technology which apparently can
only be done with a quantum computer
I'll take it
all right let's thanks Donald for OK
[Applause]
you